on m'a fait croire que ma maman était
très jeune que ma maman était décédée en
couches et que j'étais le fruit d'un
viol de guerre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
e
on m'a fait croire que ma maman était
très jeune que ma maman était décédée en
couches et que j'étais le fruit d'un
viol de guerre je m'étais surprise à
imaginer un papa que je n'avais pas le
droit finalement d'imaginer puisque
j'avais un papa violeur mais j'avais
envie j'avais besoin de me réaliser un
bain pas le papa que j'idéalise est il
avait l'alluré cowboys il avait des
ranchs il avait des chevaux
[Musique]
quand j'ai retrouvé ma famille
biologique ce papa que je me des alizés
je vais retrouver avec à travers mon
oncle et arrange les chevaux réalité
c'est le patrimoine familial
[Musique]
ils m'ont confié à ma marraine mme
amarelle qui logiquement devrait faire
office d une deuxième maman tout que je
n'en avais plus une et il se trouve que
cette marraine était quelqu'un de très
proche d'ophelia de gamme comme mon
oncle est revenu après les trois
premiers mois d'exil du mexique et qu'il
a découvert que après avoir été confié à
ma marraine jeu n'était déjà plus là
là il est devenu fou
[Musique]
dans mon histoire ce qui est assez
particulier comparée en tout cas ce que
je peux entendre et voir en ce moment
dans dans la fondation et même ailleurs
c'est vraiment que le choix de
l'adoption était un choix de ma mère
biologique
[Musique]
ma mère a eu un premier enfant à 14 ans
et ma grand mère a été absolument contre
la menace est en fait elle lui a dit si
tu en as un autre je te tuer juste eu
l'enfant et du coup ce qui s'est passé
c'est qu'elle sait elle a caché sa
grossesse sa deuxième grossesse qui
était moi quand elle avait 17 ans et
elle est partie parti faire de sa
grossesse dans un autre une autre ville
du pays et puis elle est revenue et
après elle a demandé à son ami de m
effectivement à l'adoption
[Musique]
je comprenais pas comment est-ce que ça
avait pu être possible en fait une chose
une chose pareille que qu'on puisse
mettre le prénom d'une femme alors que
c'est pas elle sur des dossiers qui ont
été validés par l'état qui ont été
validés par le gouvernement au guatemala
et en france et signer on a un peu fermé
la porte au nez on me disant que c'était
absolument impossible et que aucun
document n'avait été falsifiés mais les
faits sont là
[Musique]
théoriquement qu'on était tellement
nombreux et qui avait rien qui a été mis
en place pour pour toutes les victimes
finalement et donc on sait on s'est
décidé à constituer une fondation
[Musique]